[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse la pollution à
toulouse on la sent beaucoup surtout
dans l'air vous venez de béziers ou une
différence avec béziers je vois une
différence avec béziers parce que bce ça
reste une ville qui est pas très sain
non plus qu'ils restent eau polluée mais
toulouse comme ça reste beaucoup plus
grand et qu'il ya beaucoup plus de monde
je trouve que c'est quand même une ville
qui est le plus pollué et elle en pense
quoi vos soeurs mes soeurs alors elles
sont plutôt d'accord avec moi alors ça
on est 100 % d'accord de harcèlement
d'accord à 100 pension elle a raison sur
toute la ligne
ça je peux vous dire que on est d'accord
à 100% même si on sait pas ce qu'elle a
dit qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse on la sent mais on
la sent c'est tout mais on on ressent
quand même que c'est pas forcément un
air très sain air frais propres
contrairement ici se met pourtant si on
est vraiment à 200 mètres d'une d'une
avenue une avenue automobile mais ici on
sent déjà quand même un peu mieux au
final
bon il ya des endroits où on ne
ressemble plus à d'autres moins et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'arrivée
des trottinettes à toulouse sincèrement
pour les trottinettes bas écologiquement
parlant
je sais pas trop c'est bon c'est
électrique forcément à la consommation
électrique la fabrication tout ça mais
c'est plus je pense au niveau des
utilisateurs ou ya quand même un
problème et il en pense quoi votre frère
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord quoi
les trottinettes c'est d'un jeu on peut
foncer sur les gens c'est quasiment une
énorme en une arme mortelle quoi je
pense que tous nos frères sont d'accord
on est tous très haut niveau merci c'est
mon phone ou la chine
quels conseils vous auriez à donner aux
gens pour améliorer la qualité de l'air
à toulouse de l'air alors là je ne sais
pas moins en moins de voitures
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de transport
en commun envoyé on a pris les
transports en commun pour aller me
rappelle plus comment ça s'appelle
laurent c'est ça le revoilà et donc je
trouve qu'il y en a beaucoup à y aller a
les bus si elle
le tram ya le métro et ils on pense quoi
vos frères vos frères vos frères en
pense quoi
j'ai pas de faire débat
on est d'accord à la casquette 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]